montag dienstag mittwoch donnerstag
freitag die vier-tage-woche mehr
freizeit mehr zeit für sich freunde
familie faulenzen und das bei gleichem
gehalt ein traum oder und ganz nebenbei
hätte ich hier noch die umwelt weniger
arbeitsstunden bedeuten weniger pendler
und damit weniger verkehr
außerdem könnten büros ein tag länger
geschlossen bleiben
energieverbrauch und die emissionen
werden so reduziert
aber mal ehrlich was hindert mich daran
in meiner neu gewonnenen freizeit die
nicht einfach ausgiebig zu shoppen
oder mal eben in den kurzurlaub zu
fliegen
[Musik]
außer corona natürlich können wir
unseren co2 ab mehr freizeit wirklich
senken
das lässt sich tatsächlich eine positive
korrelation beobachten zumindest in
europa und nordamerika zwischen
arbeitstagen wo mehr indiziert wird und
wochenendes tagen also hier zu den sehr
freien tagen wohl weniger emittiert wird
arbeitnehmer die mehr zeit haben nutzen
er öffentliche verkehrsmittel oder das
fahrrad und lassen das auto stehen
sie essen zum beispiel auch weniger
fertiggerichte und bevorzugen insgesamt
einen nachhaltigeren lebensstil
unternehmen können das unterstützen
wie kann man auch auf systemische
rahmenbedingungen schaffen die es in die
donau leichter sich nachhaltig zu
verhalten und dazu gehört dann eben
vielleicht auf die arbeitszeit zu
verkürzen um einerseits die emissionen
aus dem ende ein bisschen auszunehmen
und zu senken und andererseits dafür
sorgen dass wir einfach mehr zeit zur
verfügung haben um verhaltensweisen von
dem wir nicht wissen was die nachhaltige
sind zudem gab einfach nicht kommen im
alltag auch wirklich realisieren suchen
mehr freizeit muss dabei nicht weniger
gehalt bedeuten denn eine kürzere
arbeitszeit heißt nicht dass wir weniger
schaffen
im gegenteil zahlreiche studien weltweit
haben gezeigt dass arbeitnehmer
effektiver sind sobald die arbeitszeit
gekürzt wird
als microsoft die vier tage woche in
japan getestet hat soll die
produktivität um 40 prozent angestiegen
sein und forschung produktivität
steigern weil die menschen zum beispiel
1000 und mehr leistung pro arme zeit
laut bundesanstalt für arbeitsschutz und
arbeitsmedizin wird eine kürzere
arbeitswoche zu weniger stress
niedrigerem blutdruck und weniger
krankheitstage
gleichzeitig sind wir konzentrierter und
produktiver wenn wir nicht mehr so lange
arbeiten müssen
einen versuch wäre die vier tage woche
also wert oder was meint ihr
[Musik]